All right, maybe we get started.
Good afternoon, everyone. I hope you've all been enjoying this really
spectacular meeting this year.
I'm Dr. Kimberly Stegmaier from the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and Boston
Children's Hospital, and it's my honor to serve as chair elect of the
AACR Hematologic Malignancies Working Group.
The American Association for Cancer Research established the AACR
Award for Outstanding Achievement in Blood Cancer Research to honor
individuals who have made exceptional scientific contributions to
basic, translational, or clinical research in the field of
blood cancers and related disorders.
On behalf of the officers and directors of the AACR Board, I would
like to thank AbbVie for their generous support of this prestigious
award for the fifth year
and their support of excellence in blood cancer
research. This year's honoree is an outstanding
cancer scientist whose pioneering work has transformed our
understanding of leukemia and stem cell biology.
His groundbreaking mechanistic and translational research has been
instrumental in both the basic science and clinical development,
leading to FDA approval of the stem cell mobilizing agents,
plerixafor
and motexafortide. I can't say that word.
We're delighted to recognize the 2026 recipient of the
AACR Award for Outstanding Achievement in Blood Cancer Research,
Dr. John F. DiPersio,
Virginia E. and Sam J. Goleman Professor of Medicine in Oncology,
Director of the Section of Cellular Therapy and the Center for Gene
and Cellular Immunotherapy, and former Chief of the Division of
Oncology and Deputy Director of the Siteman Center
at Washington University School of Medicine in St. Louis.
Dr. DiPersio was also among the first to identify the critical role of
JAK1/2 signaling in the pathogenesis of graft versus host
disease. His seminal preclinical and clinical studies
contributed directly to the FDA approval of ruxolitinib for the treatment of
steroid-refractory acute GVH.
His recent investigations have yielded best-in-class JAK inhibitors for the
prevention and treatment of GVHD, as well as for the prevention of solid
organ allograft rejection, leading to improved patient
outcomes.
His work has also catalyzed the development of less toxic
antibody-based conditioning regimens for autologous and allogeneic stem
cell transplantation and for ex vivo gene therapy.
Dr. DiPersio and his colleagues were among the first to collaboratively
employ whole genome sequencing to characterize clonal evolution
in relapsed AML and subsequent extensions of this work to
multiple myeloma.
His team identified epigenetic downregulation of HLA class II
molecules on AML blasts as a mechanism of immune escape,
leading to post-transplant relapse, work that has reshaped the field's
understanding of AML recurrence after chemotherapy or
allogeneic transplant.
In recent years, Dr. DiPersio and his team have focused on developing innovative
CAR T-cell therapies and bispecific antibodies targeting a number
of malignancies by leveraging genetic and expression
profiling of primary patient tumor samples to identify
novel, actionable protein targets.
Dr. DiPersio's scientific leadership has earned him numerous honors,
including the AACR Joseph H. Burkeniel Memorial
Award for Outstanding Achievement in Clinical Cancer Research,
the ASH Mentor Award for Clinical Investigation, the Giants of
Cancer Award for Leukemia, an
NCI R35 Outstanding Investigator
Award, and the Harriet P. Dustin Award for Science
from the American College of Physicians, among others.
A dedicated member of AACR since 2009, Dr.
DiPersio has been a tireless champion for patient-centered research,
personally enrolling more than 1,700 patients in therapeutic
trials.
It is my great honor and privilege to introduce the 2026
recipient of this AACR Award for Outstanding Achievement in Blood
Cancer Research, Dr. John DiPersio. Thank you.
Okay. Well, thank you so much for that kind
introduction, Dr. Stegmaier.
I don't know what to say, really. When I got the email
from AACR,
I
turned to one of my colleagues who was sitting next to me,
and I said, "Is this a joke?"
This is
amazing. I can use a whole slew of words,
but I was just shocked. I guess that's the best word.
But the most important thing is that I felt like maybe it
really provided some
specific
acknowledgement for all the people I worked with over the years, my
colleagues, my trainees,
my mentors. I'll spend a minute or two at the end to tell you who I'm
going to thank for this award, but
they deserve much of the credit.
They've done all of the hard work, and I get to stand up here and
give the talk. So to them, I
thank. And to AACR, I'd like to thank as well for
this incredible honor. I'm so humbled.
Now,
these are my
disclosures. I want to talk about something that
has been a recent
focus of my lab, and that is focusing on T cell malignancies.
And I'm going to talk about developing reagents to treat T cell
malignancies, specifically T cell-...
well in T-cell non-Hodgkin's lymphoma,
and secondly,
to give you a little hint about how you might actually enhance
the activity of these reagents in a very simple way.
And then also, since immunotherapies are associated with
some toxicities, how we might try to understand the biology
of some of these toxicities and intervene and mitigate them.
So T-cell ALL, unlike B-cell
malignancies, has been poorly investigated.
And here's a
data from the MRC and the ECOG looking at outcomes of patients with
T-cell ALL. And you can see that adults with T-cell ALL,
their chance of long-term survival is around 30%, and
if you relapse with T-cell ALL, your chance of survival at one year is
only 24% and 11% at six years.
Children fare not much better. In fact, children,
they have a horrible disease. And for adults and
children with relapsed T-cell ALL, there really are no
alternatives. There's one drug approved called nilotinib,
and the complete response rates for nilotinib are only 11%,
and the median time to progression is only three months.
So there really is no option for patients that relapse, and that's what we'd like
to pursue. These are some of the risk factors associated with T-cell ALL.
Well,
these are some of the targets that
one might go after if you were looking at immunotherapy for T-cell ALL, and the
best targets here are CD2, CD7,
and CD5. And so we decided to pursue the most
highly and universally expressed target in T-cell ALL, and that's
CD7, as a target for immunotherapy.
And so the challenge, though, and a challenge that was taken up by a
great postdoc in my lab who's now left to be the chief scientific
officer of WuJin, a company that was really born
from this effort.
The challenges are that the target antigens that you would go
after in the T-cell ALL is shared in the effector
T cell, resulting in fratricide. And harvesting
adequate numbers of T cells deficient in tumor cells
is really almost impossible because these patients have leukemia,
and any genetic manipulation of T cells obtained in peripheral
blood would also potentially genetically manipulate malignant cells and making them
potentially resistant
to any immunotherapy. Well, one could use T cells from someone else,
but that's associated with life-threatening graft versus host disease,
especially in these immunosuppressed recipients.
So we thought, could we change the paradigm and provide,
for the first time, some immunotherapeutic approach
for patients with T-cell ALL using
gene therapy by gene editing the CAR T to delete the
target antigen, in this case, initially, it's CD7.
And then also the T cell receptor alpha subunit, which is absolutely
essential for trafficking of the T cell receptor to the surface and for
the ability of an effector T cell to recognize self from non-self.
And so this is just something that we worked on for a while, and we developed
a highly efficient multiplex platform for
deleting both of these targets while also transducing
a CAR, which was a high-affinity binder that we
had screened for as well. This is just a
diagram of the manufacturing of
these clinical-grade CAR-Ts now, where the donor T
cells from an allogeneic donor are genetically
modified to delete both CD7 and T cell receptor alpha
subunit. And then they're transduced with a
lentivirus expressing CD7 CAR
under the control of a 4BB endodomain.
And then
these cells are then subjected to one round
of alpha/beta depletion since the efficiency of
TCR depletion is not 100%, and there's sufficient numbers of
alpha/beta T cells that
are present at the end of this procedure to kill any recipient if you're
using mismatched allodonors.
So this is the result. I'll skip ahead six years.
So we worked on this, worked on it, helped develop this, and we had
to make a decision whether we would try to do this ourselves and
try to make something for patients for which there was no therapies at the time,
or whether we would just make this discovery and move on to another topic
and get another R01 on something different.
And so we thought that after seeing a few patients with T-cell ALL
die from no option, we thought that maybe we should try to push this
forward. So we played a major part in developing this reagent,
and this is the first Phase I study here that was just published in "Blood."
Armin Gabati, a colleague of mine, was the PI.
And in the recommended Phase II dose for the CAR T, there was an
82% CR rate, which has certainly dramatically changed the
paradigm of outcome in these patients.
The first patients at the recommended Phase II dose is shown in the upper
right corner, showing a complete metabolic response.
This
was recently published, and the FDA said they were impressed
enough that they said proceed with the registration study.
So this is the design of the registration study, which is a much
larger, multi-institutional, multinational trial.
It's actually 10 institutions from multiple countries around the
world,
and there's going to be about 120 patients in this trial.
It's about halfway done now. Hopefully, we'll see the results in the
next 18 months.So we have
already treated enough patients to know that some patients do
relapse.
It's not clear if they relapse or we don't completely clear their disease, so
there's more work to be done. The other issue is, of course, when you're
targeting a CD7, you're getting rid of normal NK cells and T cells, and
so you're left with an immunodeficient patient, and so infections are
problematic as well. And so the question is how to
sandwich this in all of the therapies that these patients get so that you
don't
have a dead patient from some infection or some other complication.
And so we noticed that some of the patients had lost
CD7 expression. In fact, most of them that relapsed had lost
CD7 expression. And so we thought that it would be reasonable
for the ones who relapsed to consider an alternative treatment.
In addition, we also noted that there was really no good treatments
for T cell malignancies either. These are non-Hodgkin's lymphomas
and certainly patients that relapse with non-Hodgkin's lymphoma.
And this is a heat map on the left showing
the expression of CD2 in all the different T cell lymphomas.
You can see that probably more than any other target, it's
overexpressed in all of these, even more so than CD7
or CD5.
So this is a very good target for exploitation, and it's
also a good target for treating T cell non-Hodgkin's lymphomas,
especially those that relapse. This is just an example of outcomes
of patients with
newly diagnosed peripheral T cell lymphoma.
And you can see that the outcomes for all peripheral T cell lymphomas
is really quite poor. Those patients in that really
lower category here that relapse are really doomed.
And these are the only patients that do well.
These are the ALK-positive
T cell lymphomas that seem to do well with modern therapy, including
those therapies that include transplant and
CD30-targeted therapies.
So we decided to do the same thing with CD2 to make a
CD2 targeted approach. Same idea.
We knocked out the TRAC locus, and we knocked
out the CD2 locus. We put in a CD2 CAR
to CD2, and we tested it against three different CD2 positive
cell lines.
And you can see the red line that there was very effective
in vitro killing of all three cell lines.
What we didn't expect was what we saw in the next slide, and that is we did a
simple experiment where we deleted CD2 in a CAR
and made the CAR to CD19 as a sort of a control.
And we tested the role of wild type UCAR19.
These are universal CARs to CD19 that
had
the CD2 locus
intact or the CD2 locus deleted. And what
we found is that when you delete CD2 in T cells and in these
CAR T cells, they take a huge hit. We did not see that with
CD7. When we knocked out CD7, the CD7 deleted T
cells functioned completely normally.
So we could delete CD7, thus the background for
the
Wu CAR007 study. Now, the question
is, how are we going to fix this? So is there a way that we can get
this loss of CD2 back
in these CAR T cells? And so we
started looking at the biology of CD2, and sure enough, CD2
has a very critical function as a positive costimulatory
molecule for T cells. It binds a molecule called
CD58 and CD48 in the mouse,
and that this provides a positive costimulation which provides
competency to T cells. And so with
that
CD2 gone, these T cells are markedly hampered and
ineffective. They work fine in vitro, but they don't work at all in
vivo. And so what we decided to do is take the lead
of these three investigating groups that had developed ways of
epitope masking CD45 and other molecules
as a way of sort of disguising the endogenous CD2
so that it's invisible to our CAR to CD2.
And at the same time, we looked back in the literature, and sure enough, there
was an antibody being developed called ciplizumab,
which binds
to the human CD2 very well but does not bind
to the baboon CD2. And the baboon CD2
differs from the human CD2 by only three amino acids.
And so to make a long story short, we mutated those three
amino acids in every combination you can imagine and
finally came to the conclusion that if we mutated two of these
amino acids by CRISPR, then that CD2
was expressed on the surface of cells and bound
to CD58 completely normally.
And then also when we made those CD2
positive cells that the ciplizumab antibody could not see because they
could only see the
wild type CD2 and we had converted the endogenous CD2
into a baboon CD2, which was invisible to the CAR.
And the CAR was made from the ScFv from the ciplizumab
antibody. So this is how we were pursuing this epitope masking
approach. And we expressed the CAR
in these cells as well, and they function
perfectly well.So we wanted to
know how they functioned in vitro and in vivo.
So in vitro, what we did is we tested the knockout CAR Ts
to CD2 and the edited CAR Ts to CD2 in a
repetitive tumor
culture assay where we add tumor to the CARs every two or
three days, let the CARs kill the tumor.
The CARs would divide, kill the tumor, and eventually they get
exhausted. So this is a way of looking at persistence and exhaustion
using this in vitro tumor replating assay that many laboratories
use around the world today. And so this is what we found.
When we compare the knockout, which is the black line here, to
the edited
CAR Ts, there's a dramatic difference in the expansion of those CAR T's.
So our edited CAR T's really were
outperforming the knockout CAR T's by huge amounts.
And then also, this is a slightly different assay, but you can see with repetitive
stimulation, the knockout CAR T's sort of
die after the fourth round of stimulation, while
the edited CAR T's can extend out to 13 rounds of
re-stimulation, in which tumor cells are given every three days.
And we also tested at each round of stimulation that the
function of the CAR T's, and you can see by about the sixth or
seventh round of re-stimulation, you can see that there's
starting to be a difference between the function of the knockout CAR T's
versus the edited CAR T's. So that by the time you get to around
10 or 11, the edited CAR T's look completely
functional and the knockout CAR T's are completely
exhausted. Next, this is the definition of exhaustion.
They can't actually kill the targets,
and they can't generate
interferon gamma.
So this is
one other thing that we didn't expect to see, but with repetitive
stimulation, you can see that here are the
knockout CAR T's down here in the dark, and here are the fours
and eights of the edited CAR T's. They expand
dramatically. And also the persistence of
as these cells get more and more exhausted from the knockout, there's more
and more eights. And you can see in the edited population,
the fours are well-preserved until the very end.
So this preserves CD4 function, which we think may be
important for overall CAR T-cell efficacy.
And then the final experiment, we tested this in an in vivo experiment,
and this
is the results in which we put in the knockout.
You can see that the knockout cells, really, this is the tumor
only. This is the knockout, and here are the edited cells, and all the
animals survive, and they control the tumor quite well.
So this is what we'd like to take forward into the clinic for patients who
have relapses after CD7 therapy and also for
non-Hodgkin's lymphomas that require CAR T-cell therapy
for relapse or refractory disease.
So the final thing is that since the CD2 is very essential,
what Jerry Zhang did, who has really been
leading this work in the lab, he decided to actually take the
cytoplasmic domain of CD2 and incorporate it into
the CAR itself. And so
what you can see is that there's a little bit of activity with
the CD28 alone, but all of the others that lack
the intact CD2 have very poor CAR
T-cell expansion. However,
when you look at the
one
construct here in which he's inserted a part of
the cytoplasmic domain of CD2, which is conserved
between many species and obviously we think is very important for
signaling, if we put that in the middle of the CAR, then these cells
dramatically improve in their expansion and
anti-tumor efficacy. And this is another way of actually getting
around actually having to express an epitope-matched
CD2 in these CAR T cells.
So we've gone on, and we've done some manufacturing,
and we've manufactured UCAR T2
in large scale using gREX. And the way
we had to do it, we had a few little tricks here.
The first little trick was we had to incorporate dasatinib during the
early phases of the expansion and transduction because of
early fratricide. So when we tried to, even
with our
novel approaches, if we didn't add dasatinib early on, we saw
a lot of fratricide early on. And when we added dasatinib, we had
marked improvement in expansion and viability of the cells.
And at the end of the expansion, we have enough cells to
treat between 50 and 100 patients, and we wanted to
know what those cells looked like.
And here's an example of the cells that have been expanded.
And you can see that there's still 5% or 6%
of these TRAK positive cells. And this is enough to kill a recipient.
So we have to get rid of them. And to get rid of them, we have to either run them
over an alpha/beta affinity column or get rid of them
some other way. And so there is now a
GMP-approved
OKT3 antibody that you can just throw into the
mix and without actually doing any purification, and it
induces activation-induced cell death for any residual alpha/beta
positive cells that are left. And you can see how nice and clean the product is,
negating the need to do
ex vivo purification with alpha/beta columns, which will
save at least half the product.And we tested these
in vitro, and they're highly effective at killing targets.
So what
is another problem with this? So, the first problem
is immunosuppression because you're targeting CD7 and CD2 on normal
T cells and NK cells.
And this has been an issue, and we still need to work on this.
It's not an easy problem to solve, unless you find
targets that are only expressed on the malignant T cells,
but not on normal T cells. And so we did a genome-wide and proteomics-wide
screen of a number of T cell ALLs, and we have a number of
candidate genes that are universally not
expressed on normal T cells, but expressed on malignant T cells.
This is just one of them. This
came up for a screen for AML, believe it or not.
It's called CDU305, which is also called LAIR1.
And LAIR1 is specifically expressed at high levels and uniformly
on all T cell ALL cells and not on T cells.
So we think that we could even develop in the future a targeting approach,
targeting LAIR1 or CD305, which would kill the malignant cells but
not
deplete the normal T cells or NK cells.
And another approach was pursued by
Miriam Kim in the lab before she went out and started her own lab.
And this is just deleting the target in the
hematopoietic stem cells. This is tricky.
It's very complicated, very expensive.
You're modifying hematopoietic stem cells with gene editing, so there's a
lot more introspection,
a lot more oversight, and also lots of more
issues relating to CD2 versus CD7.
But in this case, you can see how well it worked in the mouse.
She transplanted wild type hematopoietic stem cells,
human hematopoietic stem cells into an NSGS mouse and got them to
engraft, and then treated those mice with a CAR to
CD7. And you can see that all of the CD3
positive cells disappeared because all of those cells express CD7.
When she did the transplant with stem cells that lack CD7, she did the
same thing, and she found that there was no decrease in the T cell
population, and she was able to eliminate any potential
contaminating malignant cells. So this is another way of getting
around it, but as I said, it's quite complicated and
difficult.
So what about enhancing CAR T cell function?
So there are many ways that you might be able to increase
CAR T cell function, and there's lots of genes that have been
overexpressed, that have been deleted, that have been modified.
These are complicated. They're gene therapy, they're gene editing, and so
expensive as well. And so we thought that just adding a cytokine, could
we add just a cytokine to enhance CAR T cell function?
This is an example of a long-acting cytokine called
IL-7 or NTi-7, which is a fusion of a genetically
modified IL-7 linked to the IgD and IgG
Fc domains.
And you can see this is a large
molecule. Instead of having to be given every day or every other day
like recombinant IL-7, this only has to be given every two to three
weeks, and it enhances CAR T cell expansion in vivo.
And it also enhances the tumor replating efficiency of
CAR T cells. And so we said, "Okay, will
it work in vivo?" And so this is an example in a T
cell non-Hodgkin's lymphoma model.
So we inject these
bioluminescently labeled malignant T cells into these mice,
and you can see that the red dotted line of the total
photons increases as expected,
and the mice die of progressive disease.
And the mice that get the universal CAR T to CD2,
these are all experiments that are much easier to do with the universal
CAR than a regular CAR because there's no confounding issues of graft versus host
disease.
And you can see that these animals had a profound improvement
in tumor clearance, but they all eventually died and succumbed to their
disease. And here on the dotted line are the same
CAR T cells injected into these mice just with several doses
of interleukin-7. You can see that all the animals are cured, and
they have no evidence of disease. So in this T cell non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma model, the addition of just a cytokine, IL-7,
provided curative potential. And this is a B cell
model. This is a Ramos B cell model. Same idea.
Injected the tumor cells and then treated them with either nothing.
And we did this in a stress dose so that the CAR T cells had a limited
effect. And then we added a couple of doses of IL-7, and
all the mice survive. And there's a 10,000
to 100,000-fold difference in the expansion of CAR T
cells
in these mice. And you can see that the CAR T
cells markedly expand as well. So it works in a T cell model,
B cell model. And this is an AML model.
This is a UCART to CD33. Same idea, limiting
dose of CAR Ts. You can see that provides some benefit to
these animals and some prolongation of survival, but with the addition of a
couple of doses of IL-7, all the mice survive free of disease.
And there's a huge expansion of CAR T cells in these mice.
So we said, "Okay, when do you have to add the IL-7?" And so we did a lot of
experiments in immunocompetent and immunodeficient mice and found
that the best time to add the IL-7 was early after the
infusion of the CAR Ts. If you wait
21 days, there's no benefit. If you wait 14 days, there's
a diminished benefit, and you have to give it between days one and
day seven for them to be markedly improved in survival and expansion
of CAR Ts.So that's also a problem for CRS.
And so when we asked the FDA to let us do a clinical
trial with IL-7, the same long-acting IL-7 in
patients, they said, "No, you can't do it.
We won't let you give the drug until day 21." And we said, "At day
21,
by that time, all of the CAR T cells have contracted and there's none
left." And so they said, "Too bad. Do it
anyway." And so we did it, and then we submitted an R01 grant,
and all four reviewers said it had a fatal flaw and that the IL-7
was given too late.
So you can't win. And so we finished this trial, and actually there
was a positive effect. And even though we were given the drug late, and so the
second trial, which is ongoing now,
the FDA let us give the drug between day seven and day 10.
So we're hoping for even more improvement in outcome.
So this is a very simple way to enhance CAR T cell function and maybe
salvage some of those patients that go on to relapse with T-cell ALL and
with T-cell non-Hodgkin's lymphoma.
Okay, the final is the issue of toxicity, which the
FDA was
completely fixated on. So they were very fixated
on
CRS, and they wanted us to be extremely careful.
And so we decided to look into CRS, and
CRS is one of these mythical biologic
processes. It's like HLH
that people talk about, and there are many experts everywhere that
have their own way of treating CRS and HLH.
But really the biology of CRS and
inflammatory reactions and ICANS associated with the CAR Ts is very
poorly understood. So we decided to do a few little experiments to
see if we could understand it a bit and also maybe devise some
maybe intelligent mitigation approaches for CRS.
So the first thing we did, we said
T cell
activation is dependent upon many different
kinases. And so we said, "Let's just screen all
the known kinase inhibitors, serine/threonine kinase and
tyrosine kinase inhibitors that are out there.
And then see if we can actually block CRS without
affecting CAR T cell function." So the assay consisted of a
very simple assay in which we took from the same donor,
myeloid cells that had been primed with GM-CSF,
a target population, which is CD19, these are Ramos
GFP-labeled, and then CAR Ts from the same
patient. And so the CAR Ts kill the Ramos cells, and the
bioluminescent signal disappears.
And in the supernatant, if this induces
a CRS response, we should see IL-6 in
the supernatant. So that's the simple assay.
And so we're looking for drugs in this assay that actually
have no inhibition of CAR T cell function, so down low
on the
Y-axis. And then also have
the percent of IL-6 is also low, and so
towards the zero on the X-axis. So these guys here.
And so when we actually screened 700 kinase inhibitors with multiple
doses, we found that devol Asib, which is a PI3
gamma delta inhibitor,
ruxolitinib, which is a JAK kinase, JAK1,
JAK2 inhibitor, and
inhibitors of the mTOR pathway were the only ones that
ended up in this select group of drugs.
So we said, "Okay, is this true? So let's test devol Asib because it's
approved for the treatment of CLL, and let's test
Jakafi because it's approved for the treatment of
mild proliferative diseases and also for graft-versus-host disease." And we helped
develop this drug for graft-versus-host disease, so we were very familiar with all
the JAK inhibitors. So this is the first experiment showing that
devol Asib dramatically decreases the production
of IL-6 in this assay.
And also, ruxolitinib does the same.
And when you combine the two drugs together, they're synergistic.
So if you really want to block IL-6, you want to block both PI3 gamma
delta and JAK1, JAK2 pathways. And you can see on the
bottom that that
did not result in any significant decrease in CAR T cell function
in this in vitro assay. So we thought maybe these two
pathways could be exploited ultimately clinically.
So we just did a couple of other things that these data have been generated by
other groups such as Marcella Maus, a group from Rome,
showing that the gamma interferon pathway is very important.
We knocked out gamma interferon in the CAR Ts, and as
you might expect, gamma went down as expected, but also IL-6
went down. So this recapitulated two or three other groups that showed that gamma
was a critical piece of the puzzle for CRS.
So
then we did single-cell sequencing because everybody has to do
single-cell sequencing these days.
And so these are the data we showed.
And so what happens is we identified about
four different transcriptional subsets of these
myeloid cells and several subsets of the T cells.
And when you add the target population, these guys here, these
PMC2s, become PMC1s, and the
PMC1s produce all of the IL-6.
And these resting T cells become activated, so they move down in the bottom.
So I'll just show you what happens with the inhibitors.
So when you add the target, these guys that are resting become highly
activated,
and that movement is blocked by those two inhibitors.
And all of these myeloid cells that are not producing any IL-6
move into this PMC1 pathway, which by single-cell RNA-seq
are those cells that produce all the IL-6.
Some IL-6 is produced by these PMC3s, which are
transcriptionally very related to the PMC1s, so they're probably the
same population.So we think that
this
provides
some information into the mechanism. And then what about bispecifics?
So bispecifics is the same thing. We mixed a target
cell, and we put in a myeloid cell, and we put in the CAR T
cell. No, not a CAR T cell. We put in a resting T cell, and we
either added a bispecific or not. So in this case, blinatumomab.
So you can see that when you add blinatumomab, you have a huge increase in
IL-6 production, just like you do with CAR Ts.
And then when you use devolucix, you block that effect.
And it doesn't have any effect on
function of T cells
when you throw in a bispecific and you're looking at tumor killing.
So devolucix and JAK inhibitors probably block or
mitigate CRS without affecting
CAR T cell function
or T cell function in the context of bispecific.
So if you want to mitigate bispecific toxicity, this would be a potential
way. It has to be tested, though, and it requires collaboration,
investment, and some time and effort.
Okay, what about genes and pathways that might
be involved? So we did a CRISPR screen.
This is another obligate kind of thing that people do these days.
And we did a CRISPR screen for all the known genes
that are activated and expressed on T cells.
And we really looked at the genes that were expressed on the surface of T cells,
and might
also be known to be released into the supernatant because our data
supported that this effect on IL-6 production was most
potent when the T cell was in direct
contact with the monocyte. When the T cells were separated
by
any distance, the soluble effects were there, but it wasn't dramatic.
And so we looked at about 300 genes, and we picked the top 20
and the lower 20 that when deleted would result in either
increased
or decreased
IL-6 production. And we looked at all these 20 genes, and we saw that one of them
was very consistent with what we knew about the biology, and that
was CD40. It's expressed on T cells.
It's
upregulated with activated T cells, and it's also
released into the supernatant.
So what we did is we knocked out CD40 ligand in
CAR Ts, and you can see what happens to the IL-6 production.
It goes way down, almost like gamma interferon, to be quite honest.
And if you use a neutralizing antibody to gamma interferon, you see the same
effect. It dramatically reduces the IL-6 production.
So CD40 ligand,
in this assay, it's very critically involved in the IL-6
production.
And then also that didn't have an effect on CAR T cell function.
And then we looked at the effect of CD40 ligand antibody.
These are two different antibodies, and also when we combined
the CD40 ligand antibody with a gamma interferon
antibody, you can see that the IL-6 production is actually below
baseline. So if you really want to knock out
IL-6 production, you either combine a PI3 kinase gamma delta
inhibitor, which actually blocks CD40 ligand
signaling, by the way, and also gamma interferon
signaling. So those two pathways we think are critically involved.
So we did this final experiment, which was an experiment I didn't believe we
should do, and we did it anyway. We separated the CARs
into fours and eights, and we tested them against the target population,
and then CD4 CARs that were directed to CD19
had almost no effect on killing, as you might expect.
These are fours, and so there was no killing.
And the CD8s, which do all the replication and do all the bad
cytotoxicity effects, were replicating like crazy, and they
kill the target cells beautifully, as you would expect.
And then we looked at the production of IL-6, and
it turned out that the fours, which do none of the killing, are
responsible for all of the IL-6 production.
So those fours
generate all the
bad IL-6 in the CRS, and the eights
do all the killing, but they don't have anything to do with IL-6 production.
So we said, "Why?" And so we looked at by flow cytometry, and we showed
that activated eights express almost no 40 ligand
and activated fours produced a lot of CD40 ligand.
And then we transduced CD8s, which don't
express any 40 ligand with CD40 ligand and with a
protease-resistant CD40 ligand.
So it's expressed on the surface but can't be
proteolytically clipped off the surface.
And remember I told you this direct interaction is most important.
And you can see that when you look at the 40
ligand-transduced CD8s, you get a ton of
secreted CD40 ligand, as you would expect, but you also get a huge
amount of IL-6 produced. And when you look at the CD40
ligand protease-resistant expression, you have a huge amount of
IL-6 and very little secreted CD40 ligand.
So
supports the notion that CD40 ligand membrane-bound is really
important. And membrane-bound CD40 ligand is in trimeric
form. And I'm not going to show you, but trimeric CD40 ligand directly
induces IL-6 production by these monocytes.
And the final thing is we all know that NK cells don't induce any
CRS. Why is that?
It turns out that NK cells produce a ton of gamma interferon.
Everybody knows that. We've all measured gamma interferon in NK
cells. So we thought, "What's going on here?" And so we looked at
CD40 ligand and NK cells, and they don't express any CD40
ligand on the surface. There's
something going on with NK cells
that we haven't figured out yet. Not only do they not express any CD40 ligand
on the surface, but when we transduce NK cells with
CD40 ligand, we can't get CD40 ligand to end up on the
surface. So there's some internal pathway to prevent that from happening.
We don't know why, but that's probably why NK cell
CARs don't induce CRS.All right. We went on
and did two randomized studies. We did a randomized study with idasitnib, which is
a JAK inhibitor, and showed that this JAK inhibitor resulted
in much less CRS than without a JAK inhibitor.
This was recently published
in "Blood." And we also did the same with devol Asib, which was recently
presented at ASH, and that showed that there's almost no
CRS, no grade two, grade three, or grade four CRS in our
patients receiving devol Asib prophylaxis.
So there are pathways forward.
So in conclusion, UCAR T7 and UCAR T2 are effective at killing
T-cell ALL and T-cell non-Hodgkin's lymphoma in vitro and in vivo.
And UCAR T2 must be epitope masked for optimal
treatment
of T-cell non-Hodgkin's lymphoma and relapsed T-cell ALL.
NTi-7 or IL-7 and other synthetic
cytokines in the future that we've been looking at may enhance expansion,
persistence, and antitumor efficacy of CAR T.
It's a simple approach, very important, and it can be added or
subtracted. CRS remains poorly understood, but
at least our data support the notion that both gamma and CD40 ligand
are critical signaling pathways.
And I hope I've convinced you that now there's some hope for treating
T-cell malignancies with CAR T and other immunotherapies.
And I want to finish up with Bo Diddley.
Bo Diddley was a
1950s,
late '50s, early '60s,
rock and roll star. He had a famous song, and it went like this, "I
walked 47 miles of barbed-wire." And I feel like my career, I've
done the same thing. I've done a lot of different things and focused on this and
that, and hopefully this last
tour of duty will pay some dividends for patients with
relapsed T-cell malignancies. And so in the
final
chorus, it says, "Who do you love?" in the song.
And so I'd like to tell you who I love.
First of all, I want to thank Mike Reddick, Jerry Zhang,
Miriam Kim, Julie Ritchie for doing most of the work, Parmeshwar, and
also some folks in the division of oncology, Zach Crease, Armin Gabati,
Woo-jin, Matt Cooper, Sherry Thomas, and Moteni Alan
Carter, who's in the audience, who was in my lab some time ago.
And I want to thank the lab,
especially Mike Reddick and Julie Ritchie, who have been with me for
27 years. I don't know how they could have ever tolerated it.
And the clinical team and colleagues, absolutely essential.
I'm a translational physician scientist, and I
view clinical care seriously, just like
I do laboratory studies.
And the mentors.
And I have to say that this is an all-star group, and you probably
recognize many of them. Marshall Lischman, who was president of ASH some
time ago. He was my first PhD mentor.
Dave Goldy and Judy Gasson, who oversaw my postdoc career,
especially Judy, who has a soft spot in my heart.
I wouldn't be anywhere without Judy.
Stan Korsmeyer,
who brought me to WashU, with Tim Lay.
And Tim Lay, who has been my soulmate for many, many
years, surely kept me alive at WashU, did so many things for me, and really
has done so much for the field. I really have to thank him.
He may not be here, but I hope my words are loud enough that he
can hear them from St. Louis.
And then Bob Lowenberg, who has been a silent partner for many,
many decades, pushing our genome program forward,
really supporting our group and myself for many years.
Don Selden, Helen Hobbs, and my good friend that
I've been working with for 45 years, Camille Abboud.
These are my mentors. And the patients.
These are all transplant patients, cell therapy patients.
We have a party every year. They come, and I tell jokes.
This is me taking a selfie of them.
And I just want to
recount an episode that I had with a friend of mine.
You may know him, Mike Eruzione. He was the famous guy who shot
the winning goal in the 1980 Miracle on Ice
with the Soviet Union. So he got the winning goal in
the Miracle on Ice, and I know him from a kid, from
growing up in Boston. And he came to St. Louis.
He's an inspirational speaker now.
And after he had had several drinks, he turned to me, and he
said this, "I'm the luckiest guy in the world.
If I had shot that puck six inches to the left, I'd be painting bridges now."
And I feel the same way. I've been
so blessed to be around so many great people.
So thanks, AACR, for this great award.
I can't tell you how much I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Happy to take any questions.
Yep.
Great talk and very inspirational. Thank you.
I'm not sure if I got the full picture at the end.
They were complex statements and very quick.
Wouldn't be easiest and universal
to remove CD4 cells
from CAR T injections?
Yeah. You're the 92nd person that's asked me that
question, so I'll answer it. No, it's a good question.
So I can tell you that at the NIH, they are currently developing
a CAR T-cell product that's only CD8s.
I can tell you that I think they've observed a
relatively low rate of CRS in that product.
I can't say anything about its efficacy, though.
So they have
observed what-
So just take the fours out. That may be
it.
The problem is I'm at WashU, and I have people like Ken Murphy and Bob Schreiber
around all the time that tell me that CD4s are very important,
and you don't get an effective immune response unless you have CD4s present.
So
I don't know what the answer is, but it should be tested in a real clinical trial.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Maybe I can ask a question, too.
Sure.
What is known about in the case of the CD7-directed CAR,
what's the mechanism of downregulation of CD7?
Is that-
Yeah. So nothing has been published yet.
But the few
patients that have been looked at that have lost CD-- And it turns out that about
20% of patients that relapse, almost all of them will lose CD7,
and it's everything you might imagine. It's splicing abnormalities.
It's biallelic deletion. It's
some mysterious downregulation of surface expression.
There's everything you can imagine. So I think the jury's still out.
Yeah.
Thank you. Well, congratulations, John.
Thank you.
That was amazing.